[Music]
anymore
for more than 100 years america's
national parks have dazzled countless
visitors pristine places for future
generations to soak in the country's
rugged beauty but these days the
tourists seem to outnumber the wildlife
in 2019
327 million people
visited our national parks more than
double 50 years ago mark strassman
traveled to utah's zion national park to
brave the crowds while admiring the
beauty
sculpted over millennia zion is an oasis
in southwest utah's desert towering
sandstone cliffs and slot canyons carved
by wind and water a paradise on earth
it's a geological gem like the scale of
the grand canyon and yellowstone's
geysers
timeless natural treasures what teddy
roosevelt called our sacred heritage
but as their popularity grows america's
national parks feel under attack by
americans themselves we've seen the
busiest zaire national park has ever
been is
after copenhagen stan smith the mayor of
springdale utah the gateway community
into zion why is that
look around
even if they're not religious this is
their temple this is their sanctuary
this is where they come to find
peace and solitude and and feel good
there's just a special feeling in zion
but finding that serenity can feel
impossible the issue record crowds at
zion and more than a dozen other
national parks tourists and adventure
seekers drawn by the beauty and driven
outdoors by the pandemic
zion the fourth most visited park in the
system sought 20 thousand people in one
day last month attendance grew more than
60 percent over the last decade park
spokesperson amanda rowland says
planning ahead is critical understand
that you need to go online and make your
reservations for camping understand that
parking is going to be full in the park
so ride that shuttle that's in town and
really be flexible now this is the sort
of view everyone comes to zion looking
for dramatic majestic
timeless the very reason national parks
exist
but take a look down below
see all those cars and rvs snaking
through the canyon
that is the challenge
millions want their zion moment
by daybreak most of the year thousands
of zion visitors have parked their cars
and filed onto shuttles taking them down
the canyon we got to the park at 4 45
this morning caught the first shuttle
out here
got up and down as quick as we could
just to kind of beat all the crowds it's
not just zion where your wilderness
experience can feel compromised arches
national park in utah regularly closes
its entrance by 9 a.m because it's full
at yellowstone old faithful marvels the
masses one million visitors in july
alone a record and look at this image
the great smoky mountains national park
looks theme park packed the pro
which is all these people are enjoying
this incredible beauty but the con is
there's so many people it puts you off
you go wow i mean we have to move aside
or we have to go around people
the crowds have strained nearby
springdale too over the last five years
its 660 full-time residents have felt
stampeded by millions of park lovers
zion national park in springdale are
married we share boundaries but like all
marriages they go through stresses
and this is one of those periods we were
three miles long
and we had parking cars parked on both
sides of the road for three miles and we
called it the metal canyon
[Music]
scott williamson owns zion cycles
springdale's only full-service bike shop
in two years booming demand has tripled
his fleet to 150 bikes business is so
good he's worried for the park the high
season is nine months out of the year
moving towards 12 and moving towards 12.
do you sometimes scratch your head and
say where are all these people coming
from i talk to and have lots of friends
over the last few years that have
stopped coming back because of how
popular it is but the most significant
threat may be to the parks themselves
where the conservation motto is leave no
trace instead people leave trash or
reminders etched in stone of their visit
part of the problem funding congress is
forcing the parks to do more with less
do you worry for the future of the park
concern the park is my business if it
turns into something ugly i lose
business i can't afford to not have the
park
zion's on track to hit nearly 5 million
visitors this year
at 229 square miles it's especially
small and unusual in that 99 percent of
visitors get funneled through a single
canyon the great outdoors quickly can
feel claustrophobic will we reach a
point where there's so much traffic
there's genuine concern for the park
itself
i mean that's a larger discussion about
parks in general right we need to be
asking ourselves what does that look
like what does that mean
important questions for the park service
some have introduced timed entry or
ticket requirements to control crowds
trying to leave the drama to the scenery
for cbs saturday morning i'm mark
strassman at zion national park
i think one great key is there's a lot
of out of the way places in these parks
that you can check out just don't away
from the crowd don't follow the crowd
the good and the bad right